well I want to start today with how
Republicans are continuing to use
anti-intellectualism and
pseudo-intellectualism to divide America
and very specifically and overtly to try
to win elections not in a vague sense
they're trying to win today in Georgia
by using anti-intellectualism to divide
America and to create this Narrative of
Good and Evil right and wrong Elite and
working man or whatever sort of black
white framing you want to use I was
doing research for a story that I was
going to bring to you today and it's a
clip of Republican senator John Kennedy
where he talks about oh don't let these
high IQ people this that and the other
thing all in a defense of why we should
or Georgians should vote tonight in the
December runoff uh December 6 runoff
which is which is today in Georgia for
Herschel Walker rather than Raphael
Warnock the framing being okay Herschel
Walker might be kind of dumb but don't
let these high IQ people tell you that
they're the ones you should be voting
for or whatever the case may be and in
doing my research for this I came across
a really great article that says just
about everything that needs to be said
as well as it can be said by Jason
Easley and Sarah Jones and so we're
going to link to the article
um but but it gives us a great jumping
off point for this discussion and in the
article uh Jason and Sarah write how
Republicans are using
anti-intellectualism to divide America
Senator John Kennedy's comments on high
IQ stupid people show that Republicans
have weaponized anti-intellectualism to
divide America
anti-intellectualism is nothing new in
the Republican party they write but
Senator John Kennedy used Herschel
Walker's lack of intellect as a selling
point while urging Republicans to
despise anyone with a high IQ now we're
going to look at a clip and of course
the irony of this is well you might
figure out the irony but let's play the
clip first
and these high IQ stupid people have an
answer for everything
you know why
because they think they're smarter and
more virtuous than the American people
these woke
high IQ stupid people they're easy to
recognize
easy to recognize this is there are so
many subtexts here but let's keep
playing it
they hate George Washington ah they hate
Thomas Jefferson
they hate Dr Zeus and they hate Mr
Potato Head Dr Zeus by the way okay
these woke
you stupid people they walk around they
walk around with Ziploc bags of kale
that they can eat to give them energy
now if you want food does provide energy
to the body that's true
I don't eat kale you know why
because kale tastes to me like I'd
rather be fat
okay there is so there's a lot there to
comment on and I'm not going to comment
on a lot of it
notice how John Kennedy talks about how
you can tell
who the high IQ stupid people are
one of the Tells to some degree is the
way people speak of course and maybe in
hearing John Kennedy speak because of
his accent maybe he's not supposed to
read like one of those high IQ stupid
people but we know that John Kennedy is
playing a character and part of the
character is a character developed to
appeal to exactly the types of people
that vote for Republicans because when
you actually try to figure out well who
is this John Kennedy guy John Kennedy
has a degree from Vanderbilt University
and then he has a law degree from the
University of Virginia School of Law and
then he went to Magdalene College after
that I'm trying to see what exactly
degree he has uh he has from there
Magdalene College he got a
um an additional degree there okay I'm
not sure exactly what he does he has a
Juris doctor that that is I know that we
don't in the U.S we don't refer to
lawyers as doctors in some other
countries like in Argentina lawyers are
generally called doctors just sort of
like like Dr Jill Biden is a doctor of
Education doesn't matter he has a
doctorate a Juris doctor he is one of
those very people but at the same time
he has developed a character wherein he
is not one of those people and it's
because anti-intellectualism is a
product
it's a package that is being sold to
divide America regardless of who
actually are the so-called high IQ or
low IQ people now you could argue John
Kennedy doesn't have a lot of Street
smarts maybe not a lot of common sense
but to argue that he is dramatically
different than these high IQ people uh
that he is criticizing is is really just
not the case and this is exactly how
they frame these arguments when it's
convenient when it's convenient to them
they say listen
we've got brilliant people in our party
Ron DeSantis who went to Harvard I think
if I recall correctly Ted Cruz who went
to Harvard
when it's not convenient going to
Harvard and even getting a law degree
from Harvard I mean you've got it's
sometimes it's great to have a law
degree from Harvard sometimes it's a
signal of Epic never-ending wokeness and
progressivism and Harvard is racist then
going to Harvard is bad it's just
whatever is convenient and when you go
to them and you actually say I I haven't
heard it done but if you go to them and
you say hey is having a law degree from
Harvard a good thing or a bad thing when
it comes to who should be leading the
country well you know that depends David
that really depends it's much more
complicated than that oh so then it's
not really about having a law degree
from Harvard is it right now they're
using all of this simply to try to
justify voting for Herschel Walker
because they don't want a republican
Rafael Warnock to continue being a
senator uh representing the state of
Georgia that's as simple as it is the
topic more generally if it's interesting
to you
we've done so much content on it a few
things you can check out on the YouTube
channel include the video why are people
falling for fake intellectualism you can
also find the video on my YouTube
channel why is pseudo-intellectualism so
appealing and then lastly and there's
many more but of the three that I'll
highlight if you want to see this
ideology applied specifically to
something more recent like the pandemic
the video the disgusting
anti-intellectualism in the covid-19
pandemic you can also just search my
YouTube channel for words like
intellectual or intellectualism and you
will find a treasure Trove of content
before you go if you enjoyed this video
and want to see more please make sure to
subscribe to my YouTube channel you can
click the Subscribe button below or
above or wherever it is on your screen
and if you want to support my work even
more strongly the best way is to get a
membership at joinpakman.com com And
subscribe to the podcast for the David
packman show there you can check out
interviews longer clips and much more
it's on all the big podcasting platforms
just search for the David packman show
and all the links are also Down Below in
the video description